New court filings tonight in
the Dominion versus Fox News
lawsuit included in the new filings
this new information.
Laura Ingram,
as soon as the week
after the 2020 election
quote made the decision not to air
the false allegations of dominion.
This is what she said in her deposition.
These, of course are allegations
at the heart of the lawsuit
that Dominion voting machines changed
votes and masse.
This is a sign in the case of Ingram
that she knew very early
that teams Trump's
claims of election fraud were false.
Paula Reid is OUTFRONT.
And Paula, what else do these filings
tell us?
Well, Erin,
they suggest that Fox News
could lose this case
because usually defamation
is very difficult to prove.
The bar is high.
You have to show actual malice
that someone knew they were lying.
And the evidence that we're seeing here
from from Tucker Carlson and others
strongly suggests that they did know
these claims
about the election were not true.
And they said them anyway.
And why did they do that?
Well, these documents reveal
it was all about money and ratings
They could not have been.
This is the Tucker Carlson
America series on camera.
The outcome of our presidential election
was seized from the hands of voters.
But New Court documents
revealing a very different Carlson
behind the scenes,
texting a producer on January 4th.
20, 21
just two days before the Capitol attack.
Saying of Trump, I hate him passionately.
I can't handle much more of this.
We are very, very close
to being able to ignore Trump.
Most nights
admitting what a disaster it's been
is too tough to digest.
But come on,
there isn't really an upside to Trump.
Those private remarks,
a total contrast
to Carlson's
public comments
like this at a conservative event
just a few months ago.
I actually love Donald Trump as a guy.
I'm so grateful
that Donald Trump ran in 2016.
Donald Trump like
Donald
Trump completely changed
my view of everything.
His private messages were released
as part of Dominion Voting Systems,
$1.6 billion defamation lawsuit
against the right wing network,
revealing that Fox
News stars and top executives
didn't actually believe
the lie they put on air
that the 2020 election was stolen.
But amid falling ratings,
the network continued to promote Trump
and his lies.
Voter fraud is something that is real.
That just took place two weeks ago.
What happened
was the people in charge rigged the game.
Despite his prior
personal objections to Trump,
Carlson continues
to support him publicly.
Defending him
after a search
warrant was executed at Mar a Lago.
No honest person could believe
that the raid
on Donald Trump's
home last week was a legitimate
act of law enforcement. It was not.
And seen here
laughing with Trump at a golf tournament
over the summer
We expect additional
evidence to be released tonight
and the next legal development occurs
in two weeks.
There will be a hearing
when both sides
will try to convince a judge
to resolve this case in their favor
without a trial.
If that doesn't work,
they could settle before
this is scheduled to go to trial on
April 17th Erin.
All right, Paula, thank you very much.
And laying all that out
is amazing to see it.
OUTFRONT now, Jonah Goldberg,
he left Fox after 12 years
after 12 years there
because Tucker Carlson
suggested January
six was a false flag operation.
And of course, Jonah,
I just have to note,
you were subpoenaed
and deposed by Dominion in this case.
You can't speak about that
deposition, obviously.
So let me just start, though,
with what is so jarring here
in what we're learning,
the difference
between what Tara
Tucker Carlson said about Trump
in public versus private.
Right. There's no nuance.
There's no reading between the lines
I mean,
this is
just as as starkly clear
as it can get in private.
Quote, I hate him passionately.
There isn't really an upside
to Trump, a demonic force.
And we just heard him publicly.
You've known him for decades.
Did you know that what his real feelings
were about Trump,
that he passionately hated him
demonic for stuff like that?
Well, I mean, look, I mean,
the few times we talked about Trump
he could be, you know,
critical of the guy.
But I don't remember ever saying
I hate him
passionately
or any of that kind of thing.
I think the thing to keep in mind
about Tucker is,
first of all, he's a lot smarter
than a lot of the other people
playing the same game
that Tucker is playing.
Yeah.
And one of the things that you get
when you have
that when you're that smart is
you're
not only just good at lying
to the audience,
you're good at lying to yourself.
And so when you listen,
actually, that clip that you ran
in the setup piece
about how
he's grateful that Trump ran,
it made him change everything,
how he thinks about everything.
I think that there's a lot of truth
to that insofar
as Trump made get created
a whole new permission structure
for a lot of people
to just turn on fire hoses of B.S.
and monetize
it and sell off, aggrandize from it.
And I think that
that Tucker learned from that.
And I think he's grateful
for that, that new environment,
because he's thrived it.
Now, you know, the thing
the reality in these
in this case, right as this is laid out
and you're talking about defamation,
serious things that could
threaten threatened Fox News itself
or its existence,
depending how this case goes.
Tucker Carlson,
has been a ratings leader there. Right.
He's been the conversation driver for Fox
now for years.
Does this lawsuit, Jonah, as you see
it, threaten
that his show,
his professional, professional existence?
Well, you might think it
would, except he's
kind of spent the last week
since the Dominion, the latest Dominion
revelations doubling
and tripling down on the act.
So maybe he knows something
or has a theory of the case.
Maybe he thinks he's on fire,
but maybe he's, you know,
playing a
stop me before I kill again
game with with Rupert
trying to get himself fired
so he can make himself a martyr.
I don't know what's
going through his head.
I don't think this is fatal.
This will be fatal for Fox.
It would be a big blow.
I think it could trigger
shareholder lawsuits,
all sorts of things. But they could.
You know, Fox is a giant ATM machine
It is not something
that they want to lose for sure.
And I do think that there is going to be
a considerable bloodletting
down the road.
I don't know
if Tucker will get the ax,
but I, I would not buy a lot of stock.
And Fox CEO Susan Scott at this point.
She seems to be getting groomed
sort of like a Thanksgiving turkey.
Why are you giving me all this good food
lately?
So I think she's going to go.
But
the real trick is when Tucker's
audience realizes that he's playing them.
And until they do, he's
he's going to remain
popular, is going to remain
faithful to them.
He considers his role,
as far as I can tell,
to simply
be the voice of his biggest fans.
And he's not going to disappoint them.
He's kind of like
Ferris Bueller
running out in front of the parade
thinking he's leading it.
He's taking cues from the audience
and he is doing fan service for them.
All right.
Well, Jonah, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Fascinating perspective.
Such insight, given how much you know.